[Music]
this story is something that happened a
little over a month ago it's not new but
uh the family of this victim have still
not received
answers for what happened and it's it's
a really sad thing uh we had a lot of
dms to the uh jk instagram asking us to
cover this at the time but i
i i the best i could do then was just
kind of put some shed some light
using ig stories
there was a film student
from chapman college his name was peng
wang
and he had joined up with some other
student directors from usc to do a
little short film at glamis like in the
desert sand dunes oh man glamis is crazy
yeah so they went and rented uh why is
it crazy so it's imagine like you're in
the sahara desert but you're in
california arizona so it's just nothing
but real just sand dunes sand dunes once
you're there you're i'm just like am i
still in america
it looks like that it looks like you're
at the beach but there's no beach it's
just sand and it's it's mountains it's
huge yeah
it's like tattooing in dude yeah
tatooine and i slid down all the way i
was like yeah and i [ __ ] had santa
all up in my butt it was nice yeah it's
a it's a place uh you have to rent a
specific type of vehicle obviously to
drive on it uh so they rented a bunch of
gear from the school so that meant that
the project itself was like a school
sanctioned type thing
um they rented one of those mavericks
you know like this four wheel drive kind
of like sand rail things to take
and it rolled
and then uh penguin was the only guy
that didn't have a safety harness on he
died how i rolled on him oh oh like he
rolled on top uh
ouch he was partially ejected was what
they said like it went like that yeah
yeah yeah when you hear partially
ejected that kind of probably means that
it it rolled he
probably fell out yeah i think but
you're not gonna die if you fall out
onto sand so
i mean a lot of times things roll they
roll over you if you're if you're going
up uh
a dune
and it's gonna roll back you're not
secured
so you know a couple people that rolled
and got injured well i mean barn gio
rolled but they didn't get injured gina
wrote and got like a head [ __ ] thing
yeah you tend to not really even the
company that had leased the vehicle they
don't have any incidents of it rolling
and someone being hurt ever because as
long as you're strapped in it's like a
roll it's the rope where your seat belt
yeah but uh one thing that isn't really
right is they shouldn't have been
allowed to do that
apparently because if this was something
through usc film school like everything
that you do when you're doing like a
student film through a university it's
so meticulously permitted you just can't
like make decisions like hey let's get
it [ __ ] 4x4 like no the school is
probably gonna not want you to do that
like it's gonna be all these like
different red tape you know so uh
there's a lot of unanswered things on
what happened here worst of all is his
family is in china and they were just
trying to get his body like back over
there but there's i think they're still
waiting on just like any kind of details
about how this happened and
yeah it's really sad and they can't get
the body because of like covet or
something or just autopsy they're like i
couldn't find anything on whether or not
they were able to get his body to china
or there was a gofundme to bring him uh
to bring them here and that's the one
that i was reposting on the jkig
and uh i don't know if they successfully
did either of those things
but uh
yeah it's just a big
uh a lot of the families in the dark
about it so it's not going well jesus
really sad because uh
yeah this this kid was like he's not a
kid i think he's penguin's like 29 or
something but
you know student film uh
dude that uh came from china to live his
dream out here and
yeah there's just a lot of things in
place that should have prevented this
that the school
kind of should be at fault for yeah
because it seems kind of odd for them to
go all the way out there for just a
student film right as far as like all
the other stuff that comes with it yeah
because if you're i think it i know
there's a thing where if you're renting
equipment from the school for a shoot
then that automatically means that like
you know the school has to sign off on
what you're going to do with it
you know but that would make sense right
so they couldn't be like oh yeah just
take it bring it back whenever it's not
it's not a time-based thing it's a usage
thing it's like oh what's what's it
gonna be used for how why where you're
taking the sand yeah exactly so someone
overlooked it now yeah and even though
like you know like student film stuff
there they are they do get pretty
ambitious of course because you know
they're just trying to
uh
your experience isn't really the highest
but yet you're trying to do things that
are you know larger than life and in
this case you know people do try to do
courageous things but still the school
sort of has a protocol knowing that
that's the culture of student films yeah
that's true yeah yeah yeah still
happened it still happened to you
exactly you said he wasn't wearing a
seatbelt he wasn't strapped in what
about the rest of the crew what did they
have to say they were wearing their
harnesses yeah three out of
four of them were right now they didn't
know why he wasn't wearing a harness was
he filming that's a thing they don't
know
but as a photographer i i would
absolutely be strapped in if i was yeah
yeah but also you look at stunts too
like so yeah but i also like what's
interesting though is like i always
think about like saving the gear first
before saving myself
yeah
what if he was trying to do that if i
fall like i'm definitely gonna roll with
the gear
protected or what if he was trying to
get a specific type of shot yeah so he
wasn't like i think you just don't have
the appointment to do that
i mean yeah i've done some things where
i probably shouldn't have like right
lean out of a drifting car a little too
much not wearing anything like that
could have gone bad one of the craziest
things you've ever done i would probably
say that yeah yeah i'd probably say that
like
like halfway out of a car like doing a
180 and then filming another shot though
it was worth it though have you ever
been in a helicopter before no but i'd
like to i mean like eventually i like to
take
what i do
um film wise but do the stunt with the
person doing the stunt so this is like i
have performance anxiety i don't want to
do it on camera but i want to film it
but then also do it and experience it so
i think that would be a good way to to
experience and do the thing that i love
has anybody
been on a helicopter before yeah i have
no what did you have a question about
cultural
yeah it's dope i did uh i did one of
those like helicopter tours of la which
i thought was interesting
how sick was it how sick
i think it was decently sick you want to
do one there's one that goes from vegas
to the grand canyon and at the end of it
uh we don't have to do this but if you
want to they have a picnic and then they
they bust out sandwiches for you and
stuff i love picnics you don't want to
go you've never been on a helicopter
i've never been on a helicopter before
but but i always have trouble
it's cheaper to do that in nevada and
there's a romantic dinner uh or lunch
for two that they set up at the end of
the you land in the middle of the grand
canyon and then they have a picnic table
ready you should take nicki to do that
but make her pay for it oh i want to
celebrate though she's gonna have to pay
for it because i can't probably get four
a.m
i mean that is a big thing skydive
filming skydive filming yeah what's the
craziest thing you've ever filmed where
you're like oh [ __ ] i was about to die i
think i did a lot of those and i just
don't remember because i mean
you you edit my vlog too but like
i just
i think i in the moment you're just like
i gotta get this shot and then later i'm
like man that was so stupid i think one
of them was um on a forklift when we
were going up yeah and i was on top of
the forklift and then they were using
the forklift to help me get on top of a
roof
and then i was walking on the roof and
it was like made out of the um aluminum
sheet metal sheet metal and i was like
man this feels like it's a soda can like
i could fall right through right now
and then i had to jump back on a
forklift to get
and i was just like i don't know no
safety lines no nothing the craziest
thing i saw you film when i was editing
your vlog was you climbing this gigantic
rock with darien and i was like that
[ __ ] looks dangerous because if you slip
that's it yeah it's always much harder
because it's like the person's climbing
without the gear oh you have to climb
with the gear like yeah
i'd say you climbing things is probably
the most dangerous that's true
yeah it's just a little hamster
that's that's kind of what makes it sad
it's like we've all done jackass like
things for the shot
but like this dude was supposed to be a
lot safer because he's with this it's
like a school sanction thing and he's in
film school we had no [ __ ] reason to
film what we were doing it just makes it
all the more like oh man that's
unfortunate you know i try i trust other
people less when they drive so like i
wouldn't want to film too much like that
yeah but then when i drive it's okay if
people are like doing crazy [ __ ] because
i know like what i'm doing like i'm not
gonna yeah it's like yeah i'm like all
right i gotta make sure that you know
they're not gonna die
but when they're driving i could see
that people are like
trying to still be in the fun too like
they're not focusing on the driving
we're like in a truck bed like recording
and i'm just like pay attention
[ __ ] or like they're like going
a little too fast and hard and i'm like
we're filming dude like you don't have
to be a part of the action like
right yeah when i was 15 there's a video
of me i i wanted to um
be one of those cool stunt guys i had my
friend on my street drive and i wanted
to like roll over the car like as he
like drove
and then uh he of course like
we it's almost like we had an unspoken
role that like we all were gonna go a
little too far to make something even
crazier happen so we went faster and i
was like yes and then like it was so
fast that like i didn't roll in time and
i hit my head on the windshield and did
a backflip off of the car
and i landed on top of the car like on
my stomach
and i was like that is the coolest [ __ ]
ever did you get it yeah i got it yeah
yeah i'll show it to you guys but the
sucky thing is that like it's like [ __ ]
i wasn't rolling
that's the sucky thing is that of course
a guy like me would [ __ ] live
and like a dude like this you know just
so happens like there's so many people
that are being careful and you know
always living and also having people
looking out for them were supposed to be
and yet still
yeah
[ __ ] could just go bad you should never
[ __ ] know that's why right now we
don't know yet who is going to take
responsibility we don't know yet if
it'll go to the driver of oh yeah
because they're investigating that too
if that guy did something yeah if he did
a maneuver thing like it could go in so
many directions maybe they weren't
allowed to even i know that they um they
already found out that they shouldn't
have been allowed to get the vehicle oh
really and the school uh
were the ones that were like yeah they
wouldn't have been approved for that
it's just so interesting there's so many
like
levels that they had to complete to even
get to that point yeah like so many
opportunities for it to be stocked
yeah just yeah you can't rent stuff
under 21 right
um oh he's 29. he's 29. yeah i think
it's not that like they couldn't rent it
from the uh rental company it's that as
a school-sanctioned project the school
wouldn't have allowed them to do oh
god it would not be very lit it would
not be green light exactly yeah yeah
like they wouldn't be able to take the
equipment then they would have been like
all right nope not doing any of this
yeah so they just didn't tell them so
we'll see what happens with that but it
is really sad that you know uh for
anybody looking at this and going yeah
well they should have been more careful
it's like really you're gonna tell
entire industry and people to be careful
like yeah you know i mean
of course everyone's gonna try to be
careful but that's not the history yeah
accidents happen regardless and any [ __ ]
you've ever saved you know i've never
been on a set where everyone was being
as careful as it could have been no way
no only this one here we're pretty
careful dude yeah very comfortable the
most careful
but joe should be more of a careful boy
if you're [ __ ] bouldering [ __ ] bud
yeah yeah yeah don't be boldering with
just your shorts and [ __ ] slippers
yeah yeah because you know he has a
spear on him he has a [ __ ] stick for
some reason yeah yeah
[Music]
you